why did you take the time now to write
your autobiography
well i i wrote a book in the late 90s
which which uh you know
was was fun and we we we'd accomplished
a lot in the first
you know decade and a half of the
company but certainly a lot had occurred
in the last
decade and
i was also at a place where i'm much
more comfortable disclosing things and
being vulnerable and i wanted to share a
lot of the personal reflections and
struggles and challenges and really what
i was feeling during all those moments
and so
that's what i did and you know
with with the go private and the it was
the biggest
take private ever in technology and then
we did the biggest
acquisition ever in technology and
transformed the company and then went
public again a lot of friends encouraged
me to write a book about all that and so
here it is yeah and and it's a great
story i mean the parts i love about it
is the origin story uh pretty amazing to
think
uh you were
coming of age
in the 80s watching all these pcs and
like myself you had a subscription to
bite magazine to pc magazine you became
friends with jim seymour the columnist
who i didn't know was actually in austin
but you were obsessed with business at a
young age and you saw this opportunity
in pcs what was the opportunity you saw
in the personal computer when did you
see it uh and then
what take us to that moment when you
decided i'm not just going to upgrade
people's computers
and make a couple of grand doing that to
say you know what this actually is a
company i'm going to go direct to
consumer
well yeah i was really fortunate you
know uh to be first of all in a you know
junior high school public junior high
school in houston texas where there was
a teletype terminal
and i learned about you know radio shack
and the trs-80 and
byte magazine and was kind of the dawn
of the microprocessor age
and and so
grew up with all that through junior
high school and high school
and you know it it was kind of a a fun
thing to do and to make some extra money
and i was
teaching kids how to program
and upgrading their dad's computers and
that sort of thing it wasn't until my
parents told me
that i needed to focus on my studies and
and you know get serious about college
that i really decided well this was
something more this was something i
really wanted to do
for the rest of my life and
you know i was always fascinated with
the power of
calculators and computing machines and
the idea that anybody could have their
own personal computer and program it
that was just an incredibly empowering
and exciting idea to me
and of course i had no idea that you
know it would go from
a million or two million computers to
billions of them and you know now you
know five billion people walking around
with smartphones it's it's an incredible
world that's that's evolved in the last
you know several decades here yeah and
you tell this great story of you know
saving up money and then going to buy
your first computer your dad's support
for that maybe
tell that story of like when you
actually bought your first computer
yeah so so i i read i'd read in byte
magazine about the apple ii
and it was sort of a you know obviously
a big leap from the apple one and
you know the trs-80 was was okay but the
apple ii
was you know highly programmable and
i had
uh saved up enough money you know doing
stamp auctions and
all sorts of other kind of
entrepreneurial things as a as a kid
that i had the money to buy one of these
so i you know convinced my parents to
let me buy one
and um you know first thing i did was
take it apart because
that was sort of what i did with all
electronics
because
you couldn't really understand how it
worked unless you took it apart
and
um
you know it it was it was a super fun
time because
computers then
were
easily understandable you know today
you know it's kind of hard to open them
up to begin with but yeah if you do open
them up you have a bunch of black boxes
which are
you know massive asic chips that combine
all sorts of different functions
then every single chip you could
understand exactly what it was doing and
you could
actually program it yourself you could
reprogram the bios and
all of that was just you know incredibly
exciting to me and you had to open it up
to actually put more memory chips in
and they didn't have there was no
internet connections at that time there
was no ethernet i mean to upgrade the
machine was a requirement it was kind of
like owning a muscle car or something at
that time
which i think led you to see that first
opportunity was the first opportunity
really really that you realized this was
too complicated for people to upgrade
their own machines so i'll just do it
for them or was it the pc
i guess it was the pc 80 or the pc xt
i'm not sure which one you or maybe
which is called ibm pc at that time but
you were finding pcs from around the
country arbitraging them and then
basically adding memory to them and
taking the spread on it
for people
yeah i had a couple of businesses i had
i had the business of you know the there
there was an inefficient system of
how these ibm pcs were being
you know uh allocated across the country
and so i had this kind of flying by
business where i'd find too many
machines in one city and not enough in
another city
i'd you know generally on the weekend
when i was in when i was in school here
in austin i would you know take a
southwest airlines flight to a city rent
a u-haul truck
load it up with 50 or 70 pcs
fly to another city you know take you
know you know make it make make a couple
thousand bucks and head back to austin
hilarious i mean you literally were
arbitraging city-by-city inventory
issues and selling these to dentists et
cetera your dad was an author no the the
that that i was selling them really
between computer stores
and and the other thing i was doing was
i was
upgrading the ibm pcs you know either
buying the basic stripped-down ibm pc
put more memory in it put more floppy
drives in it
eventually the hard disk drives started
to come along before ibm had the xt
you could add a hard disk drive to a pc
and i would
buy hard disk drives and controller
cards write some software make cables
and
make a kit to upgrade an ibm pc to have
a hard disk drive which was a big deal
at the time because you know yeah
fobby drives it was like super slow
so
all that you know kind of
i i got this incredible view into not
only how people were using them and the
power of that but
the whole distribution system was really
inefficient and
it just looked like a huge opportunity
okay in 2012 childhood friends came
together to build nordvpn after spending
time apart in different areas of the
world while separated they saw a growing
need for an easily accessible internet
security tool so they created their own
vpn virtual private network with nordvpn
they're helping people stay safe online
and improving vpn services globally so
with nordvpn you can access content from
over 59 different countries by changing
your virtual location with one click
it's so elegant and simple to just say i
want to be in the uk now i want to be in
australia i want to be in new york you
know what i use it and sometimes i pop
open my ipad and i'm in italy and it
says oh you're in italy you can't use
disney plus you know what my kids need
to watch a disney film now on top of all
that do you know how you get hacked you
get hacked because you're on public
wi-fi if you use nordvpn you're just not
going to be subject to all those open
wi-fi hacks so here's an amazing deal go
to nordvpn.com
twist
or use the code twist twist and you will
get 73 percent seven three not seven
percent not three percent seventy three
percent off your two year plan plus four
bonus months for free
so for us customers nordvpn will cost
you about one cup of coffee per month
not three bucks claim this offer fast
set it and forget it and protect
yourself forever it's for a limited time
only